Florida recibió el avance del huracán
Nicole desde las primeras horas del
jueves los habitantes de la costa del
Atlántico fueron Víctimas de Los Fuertes
vientos y las potentes oleadas el saldo
alrededor de 350.000 personas sin
electricidad además de inundaciones y
estructuras dañadas aunque los civiles
esperaban consecuencias más graves
no he visto ninguna destrucción por aquí
incluso los muelles en el río parecen
haber sobrevivido bastante bien
no fue tan malo como esperaba solamente
mucha agua
los más afectados fueron quienes vivían
sobre la playa Nicole derribó casas ya
debilitadas tras el paso del huracán Ian
días atrás y el gobernador del estado
ron de santis afirmó que harán esfuerzos
para reparar los daños
estamos listos y tenemos recursos para
responder a cualquier necesidad
posterior a la tormenta que pueda surgir
el lunes declar estado de emergencia
para 34 condados para que tuvieran
tiempo de prepararse para la tormenta
esta mañana con mucha precaución
ampliamos eso a todos los condados Para
estar seguros del alcance de los
impactos
60 distritos escolares y el
funcionamiento del Aeropuerto
Internacional de Orlando fueron
suspendidos en tanto los 22 millones de
residentes continuaron bajo alerta de
tormenta por precaución la intensidad
del huracán disminuyó y los residentes
esperan retornar a la normalidad en las
próximas horas